Eric Gonzales I work on
Android apps at Udacity.
I start working on the Udacity app for
a deadline we had of shipping
the app the day of Google IO.
And so I joined the company about five
weeks or so before we had to ship and
so moved Mountain View and work late and
shipped with a small team.
The way I familiarize
myself the code base, was
really more getting acquainted with the
Udacity APIs more than the entry code.
Most of the entry code is
pretty straightforward
in terms of Android development, but the
way in which you fetch data from Udacity
was quite different and so that's where
there was a bit of a learning curve.
The activities in the Udacity
app are pretty straightforward.
They're grouped of course logically by
the activity you normally do on the site
or in the classroom.
So we have the notion of a catalog for
instance.
We have individual details for courses
and those are their own activities.
Same thing for authentication, you
have activities for authentication or
viewing your enrollments, pretty much
everything you can map to an activity
that you do in the Udacity classroom,
maps to an activity in Udacity app.
So we use intense throughout
the app pretty much everywhere.
So whenever you transition between like
let's say, logging into the catalog or
to your enrollments.
Those are all using explicit intent.
So it's same specifically I know
I want to transition from this
activity to the next one, and
these are maybe arguments or
the different primers can be useful
when loading that new state.
So we use very few implicit intensity
in the app just because of the nature
of it, we don't really have a lot of
dependencies on like I don't have to
scan a bar code or
take a picture or things that would
have a dependency outside of myself.
There is one place so
that we use implicit intent and it's for
sending support emails.
So if you're having
an issue with the app or
you have an issue with your account or
app,
of course, what email client you use or
how to send an email,
we use an implicit intent
to generate that response.
So you can send a support ticket.
When I want to make a button
interactive for my layout.
Of course when you
have in your activity,
I would have to find the view
that maps to that button.
And then once I find it,
I can set a listener.
A click listener on it.
So that I can take a specific
action on it, if I want to.
So that could be firing
maybe a new activity.
Or that could be
performing a network call.
Like enrolling a student in a course.